[Music]
new guidance out overnight calls on
pediatricians to write a prescription
for play and for parents to help fill
that order the clinical report from the
American Academy of Pediatrics says play
is not frivolous it's brain building it
cites the benefits of unstructured play
on brain structure and functioning and
its role building language in math
skills and executive functioning and
physical and social development it's all
there
her doctor Tara nurullah is here Tara
good morning good morning I love this
study because I read into - they say
they think that play is declined by
about 25 percent in the last few decades
so explain how it contributes to this
healthy development for children maria
montessori who you know said play is the
work of children and this is really
important in telling us look play is not
a waste of time it's extremely valuable
in creating a healthy adult in the
future one who's pro-social and adaptive
how does it do that as you mentioned it
changes brain structure and function at
a molecular cellular level and
behavioral level
it teaches resilience it mitigates
stress it allows children to learn
risk-taking it nurtures safe and stable
relationships with caregivers and then
it does teach cognitive skills language
skills social-emotional skills and one
of the things the report says is 21st
century skills what does that mean while
it means creating adults who know how to
problem-solve how to be innovative
creative all the adults that we want to
work with when we are older yeah and you
say because I am a big fan of Montessori
schools my kids go to a Montessori
School what kind of play though are we
talking about so the the plenty that
they mentioned with the way they define
it is essentially play that's
self-motivated that where the kids are
actively engaged and where there's
joyful discovery so it tends to be fun
spontaneous with no real goals and
really they say that play starts at the
earliest ages at birth and that's where
you're interacting with your baby they
smile you smile back this teaches sort
of nonverbal skills and it goes all the
way up through you know their teen years
and essentially pediatrician should give
a prescription for play at every well
visit until the age of two and play can
be play with objects it can be outdoor
play physical rough-and-tumble play and
then social dramatic make-believe play
and you don't need expensive toys or
devices you can use wooden
spoons at home boxes there's so many
cheap and simple things that we can
become play for kids in your house like
if your truck sorry if your child is
getting a pot in a pan and you're
singing it and do that that's play let
them do that and they say the more you
have our hands off and really don't give
them instructions and allow them to kind
of be curious on their own and what they
call is more guided interaction with a
parent and scaffolding so you let your
kid play you watch them and then you
kind of give them clues and help them
where they need help and let them be
bored they have to be bored to solve it
with the creativity that builds these
pathways that's exactly right you don't
always need to fill in the spaces every
time let them explore let them innovate
and create there's a role for parents in
this and do away with these right right
so a parent advocate your prescription I
want one for adults
I know unfortunately we lose that as we
get older and I need more more here
thank you